y'all
being an adult is hard literally the
amount of things that you have to do
like responding to emails laundry
figuring out why the drywall is sagging
right there for some reason
oh
all right can we all agree that there's
a lot of things to do as an adult i mean
yeah if you think about like student
times when you were just younger there
was like checklists homework assignments
literally teachers would be like i'm
going to give you this thing they have
to do but i'm going to show you exactly
how to do it and you can do it right
when you get home it was just a lot more
structured and now you kind of have to
balance everything yourself i feel like
i used to be much more rigid about like
getting things done i used to definitely
be in this kind of like i have to must
get this done tomorrow or else the world
will explode and the sky will fall which
i do not do that anymore because that is
not healthy for my brain i'm a lot more
flexible now because i have other
systems that help me to get things done
and i wanted to share these with you
today this is kind of similar to the
most recent video that i posted about
like what to do when work is stressful
and hard and lessons that i learned so
here i am sharing what i've learned with
you and i hope that they are helpful but
they don't need to be but they might be
helpful so stick around by the way this
video is sponsored by bubbles so thank
you to bubbles for sponsoring and make
sure to stick around to learn more about
how bubbles can help you and your team
collaborate no matter how or when you
work okay so the first thing that i do
to help me get stuff done it is to
offload things from my brain onto
something else paper another person a
note-taking app literally anything else
and this is because i've realized that i
have the worst memory so writing things
onto paper taking the things that are in
my brain onto something else is just a
much more reliable way to remember
things you know basic things like
calendar invites for to-do list items
for hangouts that i've scheduled for
like a week from now or a month from now
but the most recent thing that i've
started to do more and more of is to
just record my thoughts better i've
never been like a great journaler i
don't have a routine for that and so one
of the things that i've started to do is
i have a part in my notion in my planner
where i literally just dump the ideas
that i have it's really helpful when i'm
on the go because i always have my phone
on me and my phone has a notion app and
so whenever i just need to jot something
down super quickly regardless of whether
it's a good idea or bad idea it goes in
there right now it's full of all these
like tick tock ideas that i've had since
watching tick tock more and being like
maybe i can make short form content
one day the other thing that i do which
is more for kind of like at night after
i've unplugged from work i don't want to
open notion anymore because that could
set off a domino effect of many other
things where i go into work or social
media i write to my ideas in a notebook
so yes if i've had a really good idea or
something that i want to remember in the
shower which
for whatever reason it's the shower like
whenever i'm in the shower i have these
awesome thoughts and i have so much
energy for it i hop out of the shower
first and then i write it down in a
notebook that way when i do have the
energy and when i'm kind of like okay
i'm not going to sleep in two hours so i
have the time to like really sit down
and think through this idea it's there i
haven't forgotten about it because i've
recorded it you know other times i'll
like text myself text scott things that
are not for him but are for me whatever
like really kind of quick and easy and
dirty way that i can record my thoughts
onto something else
really helps me get stuff done because
again i cannot remember things the
second thing that i think has truly
helped me to really get things done is
to understand the priority of everything
this is something that definitely comes
from like software engineering self-work
experience type stuff because every task
at work when i was working as a software
engineer had a priority and so you might
be wondering where you go what do i do
how do i even figure out priority well
the first and foremost thing that i
think about is what is the worst that
could happen if i don't do it what is
the worst case scenario and
could i live with it also because i'm
motivated by like helping other people
and stuff i think about who am i
blocking like who else is depending on
me for this thing on the positive
reinforcement note i think about what
good can come from me doing this sooner
rather than later and on the other side
of the coin i think about what would i
lose out on if i did this this week
versus say next week and these next
questions are the things that i've
started thinking about more and more do
i want to be doing this is it fun for me
to be doing this is it going to bring me
joy will i be glad that i've done it and
honestly as i've gotten older i don't
even really need to sit and think about
these questions for each little thing
that i'm considering because it's like
in the inside of my brain there's like
these little like
meters that help me measure the priority
of things over time my instruments have
become much more advanced and are able
to be very fine-tuned so as soon as
there's an input that comes in meter
goes and it's just like
cool based on all these other inputs and
factors we think that you should do this
today i definitely used to not be that
quick at figuring out the urgency or
true priority of things when i was
younger though but as you do this more
and more i think it's easier to
understand the inherent priority of
things pretty quickly and speaking of
time the other thing that i do to help
me get things done is to try to free up
my time as much as possible from things
i don't need to be present for and in
order to figure out what i need to be
present for i definitely need to think
about its priority and once i figure out
the priority and say that it is
prioritized and it is kind of virgin and
i need to do it and act on it soon then
i think about what's the easiest or best
way for me to get this done so things
like using the dishwasher to clean
dishes i know a lot of y'all don't use a
dishwasher because it's like a cleaning
rack for you but guess what it washes
dishes and it saves a lot of time
another thing that i do is sometimes i
just text my friends to catch up instead
of like a one hour blocked phone call
because then i can do it in between
tasks and so it just makes everything
asynchronous which is also really
similar to the whole like use like a
text message communication email slack
chat app thing in order to communicate
instead of like setting a one hour block
of meeting time i've always actually
been like a huge fan of remote work for
this reason even like before the
pandemic because realistically a lot of
things don't need to be a meeting so
long as everyone communicates clearly
through text format but in case text
format just doesn't cut it for you and
being able to convey your feelings and
thoughts and opinions and show things
around there's this cool tool that i
learned about called bubbles which by
the way did you know that you can't say
bubbles in an angry way bubbles bubbles
bubbles bubbles you just can't it's just
i don't know what it is about the word
but it is cute and you just can't but
yes bubbles is the sponsor of today's
video and it is the easiest way to
collaborate with your team no matter how
or when you work okay so ever since the
pandemic also like me going full-time
content creator working with lots of
different people across many different
time zone all with their own schedules
it can be really hard to schedule
meetings and collaborate and do stuff
together and this is where bubbles comes
in basically record your screen annotate
it add voice or comments and then send
that to your team members who can
respond in their own time in the way
that works best for them you can easily
keep your workspace organized with all
the bubbles you've ever created and
commented on and shared as well oh and
this is actually like my favorite
feature of bubbles and it's that you can
2x speed through all the videos that you
watch i've been using bubbles primarily
to communicate with my co-founder for
honco academy we're gearing up for our
next cohort right now and he's all the
way in tennessee and i'm all the way in
california and our schedules are
different and so it can be hard to find
time to meet together but through
bubbles we've just been communicating
async through video showing each other
progress and updates to get ready for a
cohort so it's been really helpful
actually every single person that i work
with right now is not in my time zone
and sometimes i just can't take on any
more meetings in my day and so bubbles
just makes it so easy to asynchify
communication while still kind of
retaining that in-person feel oh also
bubbles is free to use like there's no
usage limits or like features that you
need to unlock you can just
use it so if you'd like to learn more
about bubbles then make sure to use my
link in the description box down below
after i figure out the priority of
things and i freed up my time as much as
possible then it's time to plan things
out and what i mean plan things out it's
really about being realistic about how
much stuff i can get done which then has
a lot to do with estimation as soon as i
figure out how much time something is
going to take or how much effort it's
going to take then i can plan it into my
week and day so that i can actually get
all of it done together and this is the
hard part estimation is so hard let me
tell you in teams in software
engineering you have to estimate your
tasks all the time and it is downright
impossible one of the people that i used
to work with was a vp of engineering i
was talking to him about estimates and
he told me that estimates are only
accurate when you make them and then it
stops being accurate afterwards because
you find out more about what work is
involved and i thought that was like
mind-boggling because that's so true in
engineering we actually often talk about
like based on whatever units it takes to
like do something whether that be hours
or effort or something you double it and
you add one which seems kind of
excessive but actually most of the time
i've needed that much time so say that
you think it's gonna take like 15
minutes to fold laundry then let's say
it takes 31 minutes because you double
it plus one and then that way you're
just also not like stressed out that you
have to get laundry done in 15 minutes
so it's just a lot easier i mean the
other part of all this is like it is
really important to be realistic and
that's the thing that i am struggling
with right now but if you are realistic
about things and you build in some
flexibility then you're not gonna end up
in a place where you're like i have so
many things to do and not enough time to
do this it's an art not a science and
it's hard and it changes all the time
but
planning can really help you get stuff
done and the last thing that i always
try to remember when i'm trying to get
stuff done sustainably without burning
out is that i am trying my best and if
i'm not trying my best already then how
can i help myself to get there because
you know what sometimes actually a lot
of the time i'm the one that gets in my
own way and no matter what systems i put
into place no matter how fast i move
sometimes i just have to stop and be
like okay my you go
what the heck is going on and so you
know what times like that therapy helps
um plugging from everything helps
talking to scott about what's on my mind
helps journaling helps not thinking
about any of the things that i have to
do also really helps but i tell myself
this because if i say i can't get
anything done at all it really just does
become like this negative spiral where
i'm not even believing in myself and
frankly after doing many of these
check-ins before where i feel like i
just need to talk to myself and figure
out what's going on because things
aren't going my way i've always realized
that i am actually always trying my best
and you know i learned that i have
really really really high standards for
myself sometimes so high that they are
basically unattainable and a lot of it
does come with forgiveness i have to
forgive myself that i am not the person
who i think that i could be because we
all just like want ourselves to be these
superhuman versions of ourselves all the
time because we can't help but compare
ourselves to other people and we always
feel like we could be doing more because
we know ourselves what better but
you know what i just we just have to
honor that like we're trying our best
and like we can just make incremental
progress from there because you know
what if we don't help ourselves then how
are we supposed to help others and do
the things that we want to so that's it
for this video let me know in the
comments down below if there's anything
that helps you to get stuff done that
you're kind of like wow i really wish i
had known this earlier and i want other
people to know about it because i think
we all have our own systems that work
well for us i don't know about you 2022
has not been like as like yay new year
as like other years and i just feel like
maybe we could all talk about it and
like really have a hard look at like how
we could help each other and like i
could tell you the lessons that i've
learned in hopes that i can help you
because you know what sometimes
inspiration and answers come from other
places not saying that it's just for me
but like
you know just think about it all i ask
is that you consider my perspective i
think that's it for today i was very
chatty because i'm very high energy
right now for some reason but i will see
you in the next video make sure to
subscribe and i'll see you soon bye